calling the committee conference to
order on HB 315 and with that we are
going to take a short break on CF
Senator Avis joins us in the next five
minutes
at this point I'm reopening the
committee conference on House Bill 315
and
um the first thing I'm going to do to
start is I'm going to ask the Senate
conferes if you could tell us why you
why what was the impetus for changing
the bill from the what the house passed
which we passed on a
on the unanimous Voice vote
thank you
when you included all these other
protected classes and I think race
religion there's a whole and then some
political points as well
there was the concern of potential
unintended consequences of expanding at
that that broad so we had concern about
doing that and if we were ever you know
increase the scope we would really want
to cover each topic individually have a
hearing on that to make sure we didn't
take it in the direction we weren't
intending on going in
so we thought it would make more sense
to put uh amended back to its original
the original bill which really had a
narrower application of when it would
apply and I know that that there's a
bill that we had last term so it was I
was familiar with it
and I I knew that passed in the house
last term and I was hoping
I was confident we can get it done so
that that was the reason why we did that
is that was not meant as any
disrespecting any of the classes that
were listed no and I would never assume
that it was I was just we were concerned
because we we did um we did pass it out
of our committee Nana's Lane that passed
on a Voice vote on the floor
um I I was could you give me an example
of what maybe the non-intended
consequence might be if we were to leave
it anyone just
sure well and just to clarify when it
comes to the other classes I have not
heard
or we didn't receive any testimony of
anyone raising those as a potential
defense or a mitigation defense we're
saying oh racer religion was involved
and that's why they should get a lesser
offense
we didn't hear about that anywhere in
the country never mind here in New
Hampshire so that was one of the other
reasons but let's just say religion
right people have an argument about
religion
it can be debated they get an
altercation that that's what happens
we didn't really feel that that was
something that we really wanted to cover
because one we're not clear that that
would be even an appropriate time to
raise a mitigation defense but we just
felt that
that was not really what we were
debating Mr chair yes thank you Senator
yeah thank you for that question you
know
um I'm going to sort of argue in the
alternative because I actually voted for
the full version that the house sent
over but um I know that there were
concerns raised by the defense bar and
uh not specifically about the other you
know things that the house put in
rightly but um just the important
balance between the Constitutional
issues with having someone being able to
mount a defense and balancing it with
the very important issues that were
raised and so I think
um that was the concern that maybe we
needed more time to strike that right
balance rather than we never want to add
those additional categories
I think having already spoken with our
conference that we we can understand now
um having said that we we did have some
concerns about the bill as it was sent
over from the Senate and I'm going to
ask if that you will indulge me
representative Lynn to address the
conferries on on what the concern was
and what our proposed changes
foreign
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee uh I'm Bob Wayne I'm rep from
uh Windham and the the uh now first I I
want to say at the outset as I said to
the house
um the last week
I I raised this issue because I'm
concerned because I was concerned about
unintended consequences on the question
of the basic purpose of the legislation
I'm a very strong supporter of it
um but if you go to the Senate version
of the of the bill uh that was passed
and what was before the house for the
question of whether we would concur or
not here was my concern
in in the new proposed paragraph for a
what I believe would happen if the if
this were presented to a court for to to
construe it the way the court would read
the language is if you go down to line
eight and I'm starting to where it says
provocation was not objectively
reasonable I think what would happen is
the court would put would read it as if
there was a coal in there was not
objectively reasonable
colon one if and then that would go if
if it resulted from from the discovery
of knowledge about
or potential disclosure of the victims
actual or perceived gender gender
identity gender expression sex or sexual
orientation including under
circumstances in which the victim made
an unwanted non-forcible romantic or
sexual Advance towards the defendant
comma and then the court would say or
and would put in a two
if the defense if the defendant and
victim dated or had a romantic or sexual
relationship and I think there's a
couple of reasons for that for example
first I know there was some some you
know some suggestion well maybe this
maybe that last Clause was really meant
to be you know sort of modified by the
earlier Clause but the problem is you've
got two and I I this sounds this may
sound kind of silly but it's the way
statutory construction Works you've got
two IFS so you know the court would say
what they what really what they really
meant was one if one or if two and and
the problem with if you if you if you
read the language that would say
provocation was not re was not
objectively reasonable if the defendant
and victim dated or had a romantic or
sexual relationship and you take out all
of that stuff before you know that in in
Clause one what that could be read to
mean would be what the the sort of
law school case book example of when
provocation can legitimately be raised
that is you know you come home you think
you're happily married you come home
early from work one day and you find
your wife or husband whatever the case
as the case may be in bed with somebody
else and you're outraged and you
immediately shoot your your wife or
husband and the the third party that's
sort of a typical
situation where the law has has allowed
a defendant to raise the issue of
extreme provocation
and
two would seem to say you can't do that
anymore and I I didn't you know I don't
think that that was the intent to want
to to to want to uh want to do that and
so that was my concern
if I may Mr chair right so thank you for
raising that I I my understanding and
someone can correct me if I'm wrong is
that what that section was intended to
address is that if a transgender
individual had not disclosed prior their
gender identity that if it was later
disclosed that couldn't be used so I
think that's what that was intended to
address but but I think that that could
be addressed in other ways to avoid the
issues that you're raising no exactly I
mean I think I'm sure that that was what
you know was intended it's just that the
way it it you'd have to recast the
language somehow to to change it so uh
yeah so so I and I I would I would love
to be able to say this was a great this
was my idea and I really but I didn't
this uh uh uh week uh there were two
suggested changes
um representative koutab had suggested a
change which is which would simply be to
take out that last clause and end end
the uh and the uh
the sentence in paragraph four ended
with the word defendant on line 11. so
just remove that that uh that uh
paragraph uh that that last Clause oh
I'm sorry and she and and also take out
the word unwanted so that it would
simply say it would simply be
non-forceable that that that is a way to
do it which would avoid the issue that
um that uh I just discussed but I think
that um a better suggestion is what is
proposed in Amendment
2023-223 which I uh had prepared and
I've offered for the committee's
consideration and it's based on uh some
information provided to us prior law
professor from Georgia who apparently
has really spent a lot of time focusing
on this area he's worked with
legislatures in other states I think
maybe Illinois and Michigan and some
other states
um
he's a proponent of this yes he's a
proponent of of uh of you know the of
what's referred to as uh eliminating the
sort of gay Panic uh defense and so that
is what is is contained in that in this
amendment
I think the language as he pointed out
the language was drafted very carefully
with a lot of input from various
stakeholders and it was designed to make
sure that it didn't you know it it that
it didn't go too far that in other words
that it's it basically said if if
something does not would not constitute
a basis for for constituting extreme
provocation under the law
it doesn't become so on the ground on
the basis that you know you uh uh the
the actor's knowledge of or discovery of
the sexual gender sexual identification
gender identification sexual orientation
of of the victim uh the the thing I
thought I so I thought that that
language is very good and the other
thing that I really thought was was
a a an improvement in this over the any
of the versions of both the house or the
Senate version
is that this version
makes it apply not just to the
circumstance of where you're trying to
reduce
murder to manslaughter that's the
extreme provocation part but it would
also apply in the circumstances of
self-defense in other words your person
cannot this would this would say if if
you're not otherwise justified in acting
in self-defense you can't say well but
the person was the person that I acted
against was transgender or or you know
gay or whatever and that made it all
right this would say you can't do that
and that's it seems to me that's
you know that to me that's a no-brainer
you should not be able to you should not
be able to use that as a as a basis to
say you know violence was justified
that's that's my view
we have a couple questions I'm just
gonna ask one first so this language has
been used in other states
yes it's you know what the I mean I
worded it to conform with our statute
but the LA yes the substance of the
language is you know has been has been
used in other states I should say
according to what the professor said in
his email to us I didn't go you know I
didn't go look up Illinois Law or
Michigan law but that I'm assuming he
was telling us he was telling us the
truth I have no reason to believe he was
okay thank you um Senator William yes
sir thank you Mr chair
um thank you I think this language does
get us closer the only thing that I want
this committee to consider is the
situation uh actually where a lot of
this legislation has arised it was with
the death of and murder of Matthew
Shepard and in that situation there was
unwanted sexual advances and that was
part of the situation so I think the
only thing that this language doesn't
have is is that scenario so I'm
wondering if the committee wants to
consider you know sort of adding a
clause similar to to line 10 and 11 of
as amended by the Senate including under
circumstances in which the victim made
an unwanted
and I think there was conversation about
should it be unwanted or non-forcible I
think just unwanted
romantic or sexual advance for the
defendant we could add that Clause at
the very end of this language presented
by representative Lin and that would
address the so-called Matthew Shepard
situation the only thing I have concerns
with and I want to avoid is is uh the
unintended consequence of it applying
also to a woman who a man is is making
unwanted sexual advances towards and she
feels threatened her bodily safety and
she reacts is she now barred because we
put this in here yes I think that's a to
respond if I may I think that's a very
valid concern and so we would have to
tie it to this very situation in the in
uh that we're talking about here related
to someone's sexual orientation gender
identification or gender expression
because I think that's a very valid con
so we would have to tie it together if
that makes sense
thank you Mr chairman
um with the senator and actually what
you just brought up is what I'm sitting
here going into a little bit of
convulsions over
is
and and all joking aside
a person's perception is their own
reality
and I do not see myself
in favor of anything that is saying
non-forcible romantic or sexual advances
for the defendant that that can turn
on a dime
to be aggressive
that can't that can't that wording
cannot be in here you you cannot tell
somebody that that something was
non-enforceable because the person that
started to be non-forceable ended up
becoming non-forceable you can't do that
you can't tell a person that it wasn't
non-forceable
unwanted touching his unwanted touching
period
but I I believe if we are very specific
and narrow in the language we might be
able to to craft it such that that does
not become the issue
um is this your proposed ad it is
representative I fully agree with you
it's a non-starter for me as well and
that's why it's I fully agree with you
and that's why it's very important to
tie that piece just to
um the so-called gay Panic defense and
representative Lynn did you have a you
know I looked at I looked at your
proposed language I think that you know
the way you word it that's fine I don't
I don't see I don't think that's a
problem did the other house conference
would you um any comments or thoughts
I don't mean to put you on the spot
okay all right um so go ahead yes
I want to say that I think at this
moment it's important that we do
subscribe to the house version I thought
we came up with a really good proposal
which included uh religion race Creed
sexual orientation and I think that's a
a solid way to to go about it and those
are the right classes that we should be
protecting and it seems to me that the
senate had added a little bit too much
and given that we had passed it with a
Voice vote unanimous vote in the
committee uh and on consent that we
should move forward with the house
position on
thank you
um
I would also like to if he's here um
he's a sponsor like if you would um what
are your thoughts on the um the
amendment that we have before us with
the language that Senator Whitley just
added if you have it or maybe you don't
have it yet
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee my name is
representative Sean filio I represent
Ward 2 in Keene
the amendment that has been proposed by
representative Lynn it goes a long ways
towards addressing the concerns that
were raised uh in the house during the
concurrence as well as raised with
regards to the issues of self-defense
and provocation
I think that we need to be careful not
to lose the the forest for the trees
ultimately what this bill is trying to
do is protect lgbtq individuals from
violence
and this proposed change does that
while we can address issues related to
unwanted sexual advances
that language can be dealt with at a
later time do you see it right there
though I do see that language and if
this becomes but if this language
becomes controversial
we can address that issue at a later
time because the proposed amendment does
the job it protects lgbtq individuals at
a time when we are seeing unprecedented
heightened violence towards lgbtq
individuals
and while I appreciate the house version
that dealt with issues such as race
religion Creed political beliefs
we see that the gay Panic defense has
been used it is used every year it has
been used thousands of times and it has
been used successfully and that is why
the American Bar Association recommends
that it be abolished
we don't see that these other defenses
have been used and in fact by abolishing
the gay Panic defense we would then
create precedent that a class-based
defense and I'm using class in the broad
sense of a group of individuals that a
class-based provocation defense is
unacceptable making it less likely that
a court would allow it and that a jury
would buy it by protecting one or going
some ways towards protecting all
so by doing the job here of protecting
the group that was originally tried to
be addressed by this bill
we're protecting each this is not the
moment to turn this down by losing the
forest for the trees
thank you we appreciate your input thank
you
at this point I'm going to ask if the
Senate would mind if we um took a 10
minute break and just so we could all
confer we have you have the language you
gave us
and do we have it we have
no but I'd like to see uh
yeah just so that we are all working on
the same sheet of music
she disappoint me
yeah I hope they towed it
foreign
uh the committee of conference
um and I believe that we have come to a
language that I think we can all agree
on in principle people one of the
concerns of the house
of the house conferees and it was a
legitimate concern is that in any
circumstance whatsoever that a woman
would be barred from raising a
self-defense claim if an unwanted sexual
Advance or or of any kind were against
her and she felt threatened to the point
where she would be justified as using
Force she would be barred from using
that self-defense force it is we we have
changed it so that such that this is
very extremely narrow it would not
affect that situation and it is the
legislative intent that this not apply
and limit a woman's right to
self-defense in any way shape or form
and I I would ask that the Senate um if
they have anything to say I think we're
ready to
yeah I would I would agree with that
description so you know absolutely
self-defense
uh is still uh permitted in this
situation we're talking about homicide
and we're talking about the situation
where you cannot say I committed well it
wouldn't be a mitigating factor to say I
committed this murder because that
person was gay so it does not
um
in any way change the situation that I
rightly agree with you regarding a
woman's right to self-defense
there's a difference there's a
completely different defenses one's a
mitigation defense self-defense is a as
an affirmative defense you're not guilty
at that point so they're different
defenses altogether they're not the same
and that's why with the original bill I
think if you look at the RSA it's under
the amendment that we've been talking
about should go into that section not
under the other RSA I think it was so
what you're so what you're referring to
representative is maintaining the
affirmative defense which we are not
touching at all what we what we are
addressing in this proposal is that
mitigating
okay so
um having said that um I think that
we've um is there anything else you'd
like to add I'd just like to add um that
I will be coming back next year with a
build to make sure that we address the
other uh concerns that were addressed by
the house version uh race and other
things but I'm glad that we were able to
come up with an agreement uh to to ban
the gay Panic defense which is I think
an important thing to do and I would be
proud to co-sponse that that bill with
you uh representative wheeler and to
save you some time just maybe we talk
about that off off
all right uh at this point um we um we
would uh like to vote um is the house in
favor of this language
yes Mr chairman
all in favor in the Senate yes yes then
we have an agreement and um we will get
this typed up uh by OLS and we will get
the conference sign-off
thank you excellent working with all of
you thank you very much thank you
everyone
foreign